the CEO of United Airlines this morning
said he will not resign after the
violent removal of a passenger and
growing backlash from customers and
lawmakers Oscar muñoz called the
incident a system failure and issued an
apology saying we will fix this
he called Sunday's incident a quote
truly horrific event and said I want you
to know that we take full responsibility
and we will work to make it right online
petitions are calling for a federal
investigation of the incident and the
CEOs resignation Allen Murray is
president of Fortune magazine and chief
content officer of Time Inc good morning
good morning Nora
all right the United CEO says he will
not resign but he's got to do something
oh he has to do something I mean this
was not handled well at all it really
took him 36 hours to get a proper
apology out the first round apology was
oh we had were sorry we had to react ama
date this passenger well why do they
have to do it and what what the heck is
really I think the fundamental problem
that Munoz had was he was trying to talk
to his employees you know he's done a
pretty good job turning around that
company mainly by making peace with the
labor unions but what he failed to
recognize is you can't do that anymore
you can't say one thing to one group and
say something else to another group you
have to speak private because it's gonna
get out well what what's interesting to
me here is if you look at the big
picture you wrote about this this
morning in a newsletter social media
outrage is not something they teach at
business school this is a brave new
world for a lot of CEOs right this is a
really big deal I mean to think that an
event well first of all we all have to
get used to the fact that everything we
do wherever we do it is being filmed by
somebody right it's captured on film but
then for this incident which was on a
flight from Chicago to Louisville to
become the number one trending topic on
a Chinese social media service 480
million views that's China you know that
CEOs have to realize of big companies
that they're in a whole new world and
they need a completely different
leadership that they need to do is get
all the facts as fast as possible well
that's true as well I mean he was he was
very slow to respond to this and
responded inappropriately look you and I
have talked about this Charlie I mean it
was one of the topics at the Fortune
Global Forum in Rome in December the job
of a CEO of a big company like United
has become dramatically more complicated
because in effect you have to exercise
moral leadership and take responsibility
for thousands and thousands of actions
that are happening far away and over
which you have very little direct
control so moral leadership becomes much
more important that these companies in
the past and I think Munoz failed on
that school he survives
I think he'll survive but he's got some
activists in the stock I mean if you
know they're looking at performance he
has improved performance but he's got to
do more to change the airline's policies
to assure people this kind of thing
won't happen again but to Charlie's
point about about having all the facts I
mean the video shows a passenger with
blood streaming out of his face yeah
exactly he's still in a hospital in
Chicago he has the doctor has now hired
one of the best attorneys in Chicago to
represent him but the airline policy
across the board not just united remains
the same that when they need to put
airline employees on board these flights
their rights supersede those of
passengers do they need to relook at
that I think's policy I mean looking
policy look he changed one thing he has
now said we will never again invite law
enforcement to come on and enforce that
policy that was obviously a mistake but
I think they need to look at the
policies there's nothing that makes
customers angrier the by the way JetBlue
has has done a pretty good job avoiding
those kinds of over bookings you know
someone emailed me and said that their
parent had worked for a company and that
the rule of the rule had always been the
customer is always right yeah I think
Munoz was focused on his employees not
on the customer and that was his mistake
you can't segment your audience like
that he really needed to be thinking
more broadly big three Airlines owned
80% I think of the market share here
they're all doing pretty well at this
role and part of the problem here is you
don't have a lot of choice look I was
stranded in San
Francisco Airport on Friday night for
several hours and I know it about two
o'clock in the morning I swore I would
never ride Delta yesterday I booked a
flight to London on there you on Tulsa
allenbury with a bad word at his table
because this person was stranded for
eight hours on the plane this weekend as
well that's Thursday but you're gonna
get back on a plane again
to go to your destination what do we do
there's the road Allen Murray great to
see you things here